with a whole premise of the last series
of videos was really just trying to get
at trying to figure out whether some
transformation d let's have some
transformation that is a mapping from
let's say it's a mapping from rn
to
r m the whole question is is t
invertible
is
t
invertible
is t
invertible and we showed several videos
ago that a function and the
transformation is really just a function
that a function is invertible if it
meets two conditions
so invertible
inversible i don't have to keep writing
the word over then you have to have two
conditions it has to be onto or
essentially it has to map to every
member of your codomain
and it also has to be
one to one
one to one another way of saying one to
one is that every member of your
codomain is mapped to by at most one
member of your domain and we did several
videos where we saw well we if we had a
transformation a linear transformation
that's defined by
a matrix a where this would be an m by n
matrix
we said that this is going to be met if
the rank
this is met if the rank of
and this is only met if the rank of a
is equal to the number of rows
in your transformation matrix
is equal to m and in the last video i
just showed that this is only true
if every one of your column vectors are
linearly independent or that they all
are basis vectors for your column space
or that the rank
the rank
of your matrix has to be equal to n
now so in order for something to be
invertible in order for the
transformation to be invertible both of
these things have to be true your rank
of a has to be equal to m and your rank
of a has to be equal to n so in order to
be invertible a couple of things have to
happen
in order to be invertible your
rank
of your transformation matrix has to be
equal to m which has to be equal to n so
m has to be equal to n
so we have an interesting condition you
have to have a square matrix
you have to have a square matrix
your matrix has to be n
n by n that's what this implies if both
of these are true then m has to be equal
to n and you're dealing with a square
matrix even more you're dealing with the
square matrix where every one of the
columns are linearly independent so this
is going to be so this is our a
a looks like this a1
a2
all the way to a n
since the rank of a is equal to n and
this is of course an n by n matrix we
just said that this has to be the case
because both it's rank
both m its rank has to be equal to m
which is the number of rows and its rank
has to be equal to n which is the number
of columns so the rows and columns have
to be the same but the fact that your
rank is equal to the number of columns
that means that all of your
all of your column vectors or bases for
your column space or that if you put
them into reduced row echelon form
so if you put this into reduced row
echelon form
what are you going to get
well all of these guys are basis vectors
so they're all going to be associated
with pivot vectors or they're all going
to be associated with pivot columns so
this is going to be one
zero bunch of zeros and then you're
going to have zero one a bunch of zeros
like this they're all going to be
associated with pivot columns so all
associated
with
pivot columns
when you go into reduced row echelon
form so all of them are pivot columns
it's an n by n matrix so what is an n by
n matrix where every column is a pivot
column
what is an n by n matrix let me write
this
so you have an n so the reduced row
echelon form of a the reduced row
echelon form of a has to be equal to an
n by n matrix because a is n by n
n by n
matrix
where
every
column
is a linearly independent pivot column
and i mean by definition of reduced row
echelon form they can't be you know you
can't have the same pivot column twice
where every column is a linearly
independent pivot column
it's a little bit redundant but i think
you get the idea so what is an n by n
matrix where every column is a linearly
independent pivot column
well that is just
a
matrix that has ones down the diagonal
one's down the diagonal and everything
else is a zero
everything else is a zero or we've seen
this matrix before this is just an n by
n identity matrix or the identity matrix
on n or on rn so if you multiply this
matrix times any member of r and you're
going to get that matrix again
but this is interesting we now have a
pretty usable condition for
invertibility we can say that the
transformation the transformation t that
is a mapping from r
n
to well it has to map to the same
dimension space so from r n to r n
it's equal to
it's equal to some square matrix n by n
has to be an n by n matrix times our
vectors in our domain and it's only
going to be
only invertible
only
invertible
if
the reduced row echelon form the reduced
row echelon form of our transformation
matrix is equal to the identity matrix
on
n i mean i could have written an m here
i could have written an m here and i
could have said this is an m by n matrix
but the only way that this is going to
be true is if this is also
an n and this is also an n but maybe i
could leave them there let me leave
those m's there because that's the big
takeaway the big takeaway is that if in
order for the transformation matrix to
be invertible it's the only way it's
invertible is if the reduced row echelon
form of our transformation matrix is
equal to an n by n identity matrix the
identity matrix is always going to be n
by n so that's a big takeaway now we'll
use that in the future to actually solve
for transformations
or solve for inverses of transformations